How come every time I open up anything
my phone my computer my closet or my
[__] zipper I have to read a headline
about how how amazing lizzo looks
why do I have to always read that that's
my question to put out there why do I
have to always read
lizzo was on the carpet of the Vietnam
VMAs and looked
and slayed she's a queen look at how she
killed her outfit and then I gotta look
and she's wearing literally a Hershey's
bar
she wore a dress that said Hershey's on
it the other day and everyone's like and
she absolutely killed it hey dude
no she didn't and that's just a regular
free song I didn't put out on iTunes
dude
you don't look good like that
why are we pretending the I know why I
know why I know why we're saying it I
know why we're saying it
because she's overweight
and because there's been so much fat
shaming in the world that now we gotta
backtrack and the pendulum swing too far
the other way and now there has to be
headlines every day about how [__]
goddamn sexy lizzo looks but hey what
about this her music
what about that
what about how you're making it so looks
are the most important thing what about
that
what about that
you superficial [__]
who cares
if who cares how she looks then who
cares how she looks
right
if who cares that she's a little
overweight then who cares how she looks
why do we have to [__] keep talking
about how banging she looks
who cares who [__] gives a [__] I
don't care what weight she is if she's
happy and killing it on stage what the
[__] do I care
I don't give a [__]
but but every time I open uh she looks
banging in that [__]
why don't you give the word tin foil
people be like Lizzy Lizzy showed up
boy did she slay in some tin foil
hey now you look like the Tin Man
it's embarrassing you're embarrassing
yourself bloggers
I hope she knows and she's just taking
the piss and you guys just don't even
understand her levels
hey also
she remember when she did the thing at
the basketball game and she just showed
up with her [__] out and everyone was
like she slayed
her [__] [__] was out
dude her [__] [__] was out
and we had to pretend like she slayed
dude if my [__] was out
[Music]
my whole [__] my my ass in front of
apartment blinds just pivoting and then
I open up and my [__] opens up and I
just go
[Applause]
new man on a Minnesota Vikings she shut
up wearing a Hershey she's [__] milk
chocolate rapper
hey you didn't slay it looked like
chocolate
I mean dude why do we pret and she
slayed dude if [__] Halle Berry
showed up like that you'd roaster
rightfully so
that's hilarious what this world has
come to
oh
she got that chunk huh
look at that ass
Jesus
look at what everyone says pretty
I don't know
oh what is she doing
hey you got Grandma
anyone that does that is a [__] man
these chicks
you know
they'll be on the her voices the [__]
no man on the Venice on a Vikings
anybody who does that in the middle of
song um um I hate when people say this
but I'm here for it dude because you
feel it so dope
that's the [__] dude I love it
put on a regular dress
um
yeah I love it dude
uh anyway I'll [__] make an album
and I'll show up in a Hershey's outfit
imagine if I made an album and my voice
was the [__] and I was killing it and
then I showed up in a [__] Hershey's
outfit how they would drag me
down even if I did down down
[Music]
no man on a Minnesota Vikings
uh
I love it I love this movement whatever
you do is Right girls whatever you do is
Right girls
I had a I saw a guy with his [__]
with a believe all women shirt the other
day and I literally just thought about
how like my ex would lie to me a lot
no man on the Minnesota Vikings
dude hey man really believe all women my
girl cheated on me lots
okay ah cancel me what the [__] do I
carry you know